let's play 5-0 how about or 5'3
a 5-0
any chances for eric pumpkin face on a
shirt
maybe yeah maybe on october like
halloween time
could have a pumpkin mask even
g6
um i'll play
i'll play a marathi mind how about this
is kind of my
my old repertoire back when i was sub
experts
oh first i thought that said you dumb
man that you dumb in
is probably more of a compliment i
vaguely remember c5 is a move
but i would forget any prep
so let's play this and then we're going
to follow a main line
actually i if i recall correctly
oh a5 i was thinking queen a5 is a move
but that's castle
oh did midnight rhino gift five because
i'm playing five-o
maybe i should play like tano
um a4 yeah a4 queen a5 is uh
one of the ideas here so
if i recall correctly rook
fc1
is is one of the moves and the
the eventual plan is to play rook a b
one and then slowly
gradually move up oh midnight rhino
gifting 10.
maybe i should play should i play tenno
next game thinks midnight rhino
also b4 is a move too
not sure
start with b4 actually and
probably end up trading i still want to
play b4
if queen b4 then i'd probably move the
knight somewhere
initiate a trade
yeah so knight d5 and knight a4 come to
mind
or knight b5
um the benefit with these moves is i
threatened knight b6
i guess the calculation
we're just trading a lot so knight d5
there is this move takes defending the
queen i take back
we trade queens bishop d7s first
and maybe we end up trading rooks
or comes back i have rook c7
rook c7 rook a1 bishop f1 bishop b5
so maybe i would start with king f2 in
one of those lines
i kind of like the structure though i'm
gonna play this learning a lot
oh nice year thank you blizzu
yeah trying to make it so some people
learn some things
i also think you took your tacos
for the bits i'll put that towards the
taco finely did you play me again
um you just have to keep reminding me
i'll get around to it
currently i'm not accepting challenges
i'm just joining the pool
i'm trying to climb with the rating whoa
it's oxford typo
gifting five thanks for typo
as i'm sipping the ax or typo t that was
uh generously sent
yeah again shout out to josh very strong
scrabble player
i feel like josh's wechas puzzle rating
might be close to mine
it's over 2000 right
um okay so this is all part of the
calculation
takes
and then here
i'm trying to get an end game where the
rooks are traded my king can walk in
hopefully to the queen side
you should do against the yellow oh
isn't there there's a website for that
right elo guesser
that's like geoguess right could be fun
lead skoo okay let's let's go with the
king probably
i think as my pawns are on light square
so i want to trade off light toward
bishops
not entirely sure how maybe i'll
just start with this
preventing bishop d4
and moving with the king i have to be
very conscientious with time
i do appreciate a lot of people subbing
and
some gifted subs um
distracting me a little bit but i
appreciate the generosity
thanks for your commitment oh thanks for
your
commitment to resubbing executed my
first successful stafford opening time
today
go the stafford keep it up cruise bubble
babe
and cool k gifting five thinks cool k
yeah this end game is approximately
equal but
um time is a growing
factor so i'm gonna put the bishop here
even though it's not really doing much
it does allow for the king
to maybe find a purpose in life
um yeah we'll leave the pawn on d5
a block's probably for choice here like
on the clock and
in the position
[Music]
well i'll try not to be phased
so again i'd rather much rather trade
light square bishops
because i have so many pawns on light
squares thanks for the content
oh thanks for the the sub
also that's actually a strong move
because i can't easily
can't easily defend or counter attack
poker face jokes
poker face oh yeah yeah okay my time
i have to focus i don't want to lose on
time
it was actually a difficult position
though
i'm trying my king is so sad now
now the bishop's kind of tied down this
bishop's well placed
i'm securing control over the square
if this i guess i'm okay with trading
yeah this bishop is trying to find a a
new purpose in life okay we'll
offer the trade
at this point i don't think i mind a
draw
block's gonna try and flag me though
move this way perhaps
the king is very restricted here
actually wondering if it's okay to trade
dark square bishops
g3 okay let's go for the trade
because now black's committed this pawn
and i'm
i'm ready to okay let's push that
i don't know what i'm ready to do
actually
is ready to move quickly play
and go for bishop e2
it looks really really passive but i am
holding on
now black house to trade
king b6 all
to do after king b6
hmm
my heart rate might go up for the next
few seconds
just a warning
okay
hey let's go okay this is good
luck's almost in zul's long now this is
really good
i think i'm winning now am i it's wrong
the king or bishop have to move away
from defending the pawn
now i win both pawns
pawns defended
oops okay it's still winning
efficient me too there we go okay
let's go and
it took patience it took some speed
um i mean this is why end games are
and they're a very important stage of
chess
i played really well like just
neutralizing
the space advantage wasn't too
meaningful because
um so many pieces were traded but
still goes to show there's room to like
play on for
more than just a draw